energie benzin und lebensmittel die
verbraucherpreise in deutschland steigen
und steigende inflation erreicht mit 7,9
prozent im mai einen neuen höchstwert
der höchste wert das muss man dazusagen
seit fast 50 jahren und so schnell ist
leider auch keine besserung in sicht bei
uns im studio zu diesem thema unser bild
politik chef jan schäfer jan man fragt
sich natürlich wie soll das eigentlich
überhaupt noch hinführen wie lange
können wir uns unser leben noch leisten
das ist eine sehr gute frage und wenn
wir in andere länder schauen
beispielsweise in die usa dann sehen wir
dass dort die inflationsrate noch
deutlich höher ist über 8% wir sind
jetzt im mai bei 7,9 prozent gewesen
auch immerhin der höchste stand seit
fast 50 jahren wir haben es gerade in
der kleinen grafik ja auch gesehen wir
feiern so bitter das ist teuer schock
geburtstag seit gut einem jahr sind die
preise jetzt in deutschland deutlich
über dem niveau da ich muss sagen der
preisanstieg deutlich über dem niveau
das die europäische zentralbank
eigentlich tolerieren wollte wo ist es
denn besonders teuer geworden hast ja
eine kleine liste auch mitgebracht mit
ganz konkreten beispielen wo unser leben
wirklich entscheidend teurer geworden
ist ja das statistische bundesamt das
hat heute die zahlen veröffentlicht für
den monat mai und macht das dann immer
mit einem sogenannten warenkorb das sind
ganz ganz viele dinge drin und man kann
sagen dass neben den klassikern in den
letzten monaten dem thema energie viele
viele lebensmittel wir merken dass beim
täglichen einkauf deutlich teurer
geworden sind butter beispielsweise 43
prozent teurer sonnenblumenöl rapsöl
wenn man es denn überhaupt nicht kommt
63 pro 65 prozent teurer zum beispiel
tomaten 25 prozent teurer aber auch zum
beispiel ein gebrauchter pkw kostet
heute 25 prozent mehr als noch vor einem
jahr und die ferien stehen an einige
bundesländer sind in den pfingstferien
andere bereiten sich auf die
sommerferien vor schlecht für viele
familien auch die eintrittskarten für
freizeitparks beispielsweise um mehr als
20 prozent gestiegen im durchschnitt
also es wird ein teurer teurer sommer
teurer sommer auf jeden fall und es wird
vielleicht noch ein viel viel teurer
winter weil dann müssen wir natürlich
auch wieder anfangen zu heizen die
energie pauschale von 300 euro die ja
auch noch zu versteuern ist längst
verpufft wie soll das werden fangen dann
die ersten an zu frieren also der winter
wird sicherlich ganz ganz übel ganz ganz
böse deswegen gibt es eine
ampelkoalition ja auch weitere debatten
über die frage wo und wie muss man
zusätzlich entlasten möglicherweise gibt
es und das hängt natürlich auch vom
krieg gab eine gewisse entlastung bei
den energiepreisen das bedeutet nicht
dass es deutlich günstiger werden kann
sondern eher dass es vielleicht eine
stabilisierung auf diesem niveau geht
und wir sehen auch an umfragen auch hier
die das institut in soja für uns bei
bild gemacht hat dass die menschen schon
reagieren also beispielsweise auf
freizeitaktivitäten verzichten ihren
urlaub anders planen also die menschen
sparen wenn sie gerade aufs auto
angewiesen sind im schon deutlich bei
anderen dingen und das ist etwas was man
sicherlich mit blick auf den winter
jetzt noch gar nicht einschätzen kann
was da droht klar ist das hören wir
beispielsweise heute auch von
agrarminister cem özdemir der sagt die
die lebensmittel produkte oder die
lebensmittel an sich die werden noch
deutlich teurer werden das was wir jetzt
erst sehen beispielsweise bei den
tomaten das wird sich in den nächsten
monaten wenn die ernten kommen und
ernten ausfallen beispielsweise in der
ukraine die getreideernte deutlich
kleiner ausfällt dann wird sich das erst
noch im herbst niederschlagen wir wissen
getreide braucht man zum backen für brot
brötchen und wenn getreide teurer wird
dann werden natürlich auch viele viele
andere produkte teurer und deswegen
droht spätestens im herbst eine nächste
welle zum beispiel bei lebensmitteln und
dann wird's im winter richtig teuer gute
aussichten da fragt man sich wann wird
es denn wieder günstiger für uns alle
beziehungsweise jahren was muss
passieren wer muss eingreifen damit es
wieder günstiger wird die ursachen für
diese inflations rakete diesen
inflations tsunami kann man es ja fast
sagen die sind ja vielschichtig die
hängen zusammen beispielsweise mit
corona in china dort gibt es ganze
städte wie shanghai die über wochen im
lock down sind oder waren das heißt von
dort werden weniger waren nach europa
geliefert und das führt dazu wenn waren
knapp sind das automatisch die preise
steigen wir haben dann den krieg in der
ukraine die ukraine als kornkammer nicht
nur europa sondern der welt wird
deutlich weniger ernten können dieses
jahr da geht es nicht nur um getreide
geht es beispielsweise um selbst
senfkörner also auch da wird es dann in
vielen 4 die varianten steigende preise
geben einfach weil das angebot knapp ist
und solange beispielsweise corona und
der krieg anhalten ist wenig besserung
in sicht vielleicht eine kleinigkeit am
rande er aber scherzhaft bemerkt wer
einfach das ganze nicht mehr erträgt
wein rotwein und rosé wein ist nur 4,3
prozent teurer als im vorjahr vielleicht
vielleicht ein bisschen ist kann man
sich die sorgen noch einmal
leisten dann jan schäfer für deine
einschätzung und die zahlen die nun
mitgebracht hast